♪ ♪
>> WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT CRIME
COMING OUT, THEY ARE JUST TRYING
TO GEN UP ALL KINDS OF FEAR AND
ANXIETY IN PEOPLE, THEY ARE NOT
DEALING WITH IT.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO TACKLE
AT, AND SO, I VIEW IT AS AN
EFFORT TO SCARE VOTERS.
THE IS OUR MANIPULATORS.
THEY HAVE THIS CONSPIRACY GOING
ALL ACROSS AMERICA TO TRY TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT IN
DEMOCRATIC STATES THEY ARE NOT
AS SAFE.
>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, THESE
NUMBERS WE TALK ABOUT ARE NOT
MADE UP, AND THIS IS NOT THE
NETWORK TALKING, JUST RELYING ON
THE NUMBERS, NOT A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT THING, AND MY NEXT
GUEST IS A DEMOCRATIC MAYOR OF
CITY COUNCIL NUMBER FOR DISTRICT
30, HE HAS HAD IT WITH THIS
BACK-AND-FORTH AND WHAT HE CALLS
PRETTY MUCH AT COUNTLESS DEBATES
ON CRIME IS A PROBLEM FOR HIM,
SO MUCH SO THAT HE WILL BE
CASTING HIS VOTE AND SUPPORT FOR
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR IN NEW YORK.
COUNCILMAN, VERY GOOD TO HAVE
YOU.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO DO THIS?
>> IT IS ABSURD WHAT THEY JUST
SAID ABOUT NOT SEEING CRIME.
WE SEE IT WITH OUR OWN EYES ON
THE STREET.
WE SEE IT WHEN WE RIDE THE
SUBWAYS.
WE SEE IT, BY THE WAY, I LIVED
THROUGH THE '80s AND 90s
IN -- AND WE GOT OUT OF IT BY
USING BROKEN WINDOWS AND WITH A
METHOD OF POLICING.
WE HAVE TO GET OUT OF THIS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A GOVERNOR RIGHT
NOW IN THERE FOR 14 MONTHS WHO
SHOULD BE THE FLORIDA REALTOR OF
THE YEAR, BECAUSE WE HAVE A MASS
EXODUS FROM NEW YORK CITY TO
SOUTH CAROLINA, TEXAS, IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
I'M CROSSING PARTY LINES.
I'VE BEEN A DEMOCRAT FOR 50
YEARS AND I VOTED DEMOCRAT FOR
VERY MANY YEARS.
BUT WE ARE AT A POINT WHERE WE
ARE LOSING THE CITY AND LOSING
THE STATE.
>> Neil: IT SEEMS THAT CRIME
WAS THEIR ISSUE, BUT THE
DISMISSING OF IT PROMPTED THIS
IT SOUNDS LIKE.
>> YES, MY WIFE IS
ASIAN AMERICAN, SHE WILL NOT
TAKE THE SUBWAY, BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY ATTACKS IN OUR
SUBWAYS EVERY DAY WE ARE READING
ABOUT MORE AND MORE ATTACKS.
AND AGAIN, I LIVED THROUGH THIS.
AND I AM SEEING THE '80 IS AN
'90S COME BACK TO NEW YORK CITY.
RUDY GIULIANI SAVE THAT CITY AND
I'M A DEMOCRAT SAYING THAT, BUT
THAT WAS THE TRUTH.
WHEN YOU HAVE NOW DEMOCRATS
LYING AND SAYING WE ARE NOT
SEEING HIGH CRIME, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
>> Neil: SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE
EARLY POLLING HERE, AND IT'S A
TIGHT RACE, BUT ALWAYS SENDS THE
SHOW GOVERNOR HOLCOMB OLD
LEADING, DO YOU THINK THAT IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE WAY THAT
PEOPLE FEEL?
THE OLD ARGUMENT IS THAT YOU
KNOW THIS BETTER THAN I THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE HAS TO SECURE A BIG
WIN AND LOSE THE REST OF THE
STATE, BUT THE GAMES ARE SO BIG
THAT THEY OFFSET WHATEVER A
REPUBLICAN HAS ELSEWHERE.
IS THAT STILL THE CASE?
>> NO, BECAUSE LEE ZELDIN HAS
MOMENTUM, WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE 70% I THINK
OF MY DISTRICT IS SUPPORTING THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE EVEN THOUGH
MY DISTRICT IS MORE THAN 2-1
DEMOCRAT, PEOPLE REALLY NEED TO
FEEL SAFE AND WHEN WE DON'T FEEL
SAFE, AGAIN, PEOPLE ARE MOVING
OUT, NOT GOING THROUGH CONCERTS
OR NOT GOING TO THE MOVIES OR
NOT TAKING THE SUBWAYS AND
BUSINESSES GET HURT.
AND OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR WANTS
TO HAVE CONGESTION PRICING.
THAT MEANS TAX US JUST FOR
DRIVING INTO MANHATTAN TO GO TO
THE THEATER.
$23 TAX, AND I WILL GO UP AND
UP.
AND THEY SAID THEY WILL PUT IT
TOWARDS THE SUBWAYS, BUT THAT'S
A LOSING SITUATION.
>> Neil: AND NOT A SAFE ON THE
WAY IT STANDS.
THANK YOU, YOU ARE A VERY GUTSY
GUY, THE DEMOCRAT FOR
NEW YORK CITY VOTING FOR
LEE ZELDIN AND HAD AN
UNDERCURRENT OF FRUSTRATION NOT
WORN OUT BY SOME OF THESE POLLS
ELSEWHERE INFLATION, SOME OF
THESE OTHER